bien pues en esta ocasión estamos en el
problema número 5 ok y vamos a
resolverlo dice si m s m elevado a la
equis por m por m esto es un x por m
elevado a las 7 esto es exactamente lo
mismo a m elevado a la 28 ok esto por
una parte por otra parte nos dicen que
si m elevado a la quinta potencia esto a
su vez elevado a la potencia y es igual
a m elevado a la potencia 15
entonces me preguntan cuánto vale x + y
yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto vale x
+ y esencialmente lo que hay que
recordar aquí son puros problemas sobre
las leyes los exponentes lo único que
hay que recordar es las leyes de los
exponentes para resolver este problema
porque de aquí de aquí puedo obtener el
valor de x y de equipo de obtener el
valor de james a ver veamos primero ésta
tengo que m elevado a la x por m elevado
a las 7 es igual a m elevado a la 28
pero esto lo mismo que decir que m está
elevado a la y cuando tengo ha elevado a
la b por a elevado nacen las potencias
en este caso se suman en este caso
tendría m elevado a la x más 7 las
potencias se pasan sumando y solamente
se conserva una base esto es lo mismo
que m elevado a la 28 y es que aquí está
de lujo porque ya puedo cancelar esta m
y está m y decir que x + 7 tiene que ser
igual a 28 para que se cumpla esta
igualdad y si x + 7 tiene que ser igual
a 28 x tiene que ser igual a 28 menos 7
de los cuales 21 ok ya de aquí tengo el
valor de x ahora vamos a ver si con esta
con esta igualdad que tengo aquí puedo
obtener el valor de james y para esto
utilicemos de nuevo las leyes de los
exponentes es muy importante que te hace
paso de memoria y las dos muy bien
porque aquí tengo m elevado a las 5
elevado de ayer esto es lo mismo que
decir m elevado a la y las potencias se
pasan multiplicando es decir m elevado a
las 5 por james o 5 y esto tiene que ser
igual a m elevado a la 15 y de igual
manera de aquí puedo cancelar esta m con
esta m o dicho otra manera para que se
cumpla esta igualdad 5 y tiene que ser
igual a 15 ok y de equipo despejar en
yemen ya tiene que ser igual a 15 sobre
5 lo cual es 3 lo cual es 3 y perfecto
ya también tengo un valor para james ya
tengo valor para x ya tengo valor para
jeff ya tengo un valor para x-men x-men
es lo mismo que 21 más 3 ok que es 24
esto es lo que vale x más ya que es
justo lo que me preguntaban y por cierto
es el inciso b así que ya está el
problema número 5 vamos a hacer el
problema número 6 volvemos la pantalla
no me va a caber aquí el problema número
6 porque además tiene una gráfica muy
parecida a ésta así que vamos a ver cómo
como trabaja salman con las gráficas
recuerda que siempre es lo que más le
cuesta trabajo y es lo que más me está
donde hacer y reconstruir la gráfica
para que podamos trabajar así con mucha
claridad el problema que estamos en el
problema número 6 %
ok tengo estos dos ejes y después tengo
un montón de años tengo desde el año
1985 hasta el año 1990 en este eje así
que vamos a empezar una vez que esté en
1985 por acá tengo
1986 por acá tengo
1987 por acá tengo
1988 por acá tengo
1989 y por acá
1990 ok y después tengo la cantidad de
casas vendidas y tengo 160 mil 150.000
ok este eje vamos a darlo en miles en
miles
y vamos a ver mi valor más grande está
en 160.000 ok por acá tengo 160 después
un poco más abajo por acá tengo 150
después más o menos como por acá tengo
140.000 después por acá tengo 130 130
mil y por acá tengo 120 120 mil más o
menos así se ve mi gráfica y tengo
algunos puntos representados aquí así
que vamos a ponerlos me gusta este color
para poner los puntos
tengo que en 1985 se vendieron como
como 49 como 149 148 mil casas estoy más
o menos como por aquí a dejar de poner
un punto por acá que es más o menos la
cantidad de casas que se vendió en
1985 en 1986 llegamos al tope que son
160 mil 160 mil casas se vendieron en
1986 así que estamos por aquí en 1987 se
vendieron un poco menos se vendieron
como
155 156 y se vendían más o menos como
esta cantidad de casas que es como 155
156 mil casas ok
después en 1988 se vendieron abajo otra
vez se vendieron como
140 142 mil por aquí está mi punto
entonces vamos a ponerlo por acá por acá
hasta mi punto que es como 140 142 mil
algo así y aquí en 1989 otra vez bajo
cerca de 130 mil estamos muy cerca de
130 mil algo confort aquí y en 1990 otra
vez bajo estamos cerca de 110 de hecho
que me faltó el 110 por aquí imagínate
que tenemos 110 mil casas ok y estamos
cerca de 110 mil casas así que estábamos
como por aquí más o menos por aquí
estamos en 1990 y después me piden que
una todos los puntos así que vamos a
hacerlo voy a unir este punto con este
este con este este con este este con
éste este con éste
y lo que me preguntan es lo siguiente
cuál de los siguientes incisos es lo más
cercano al decrecimiento que hubo por
año en el número de casas que se
vendieron entre 1987 en 1990
ok eso es importante entre 1987 y 1990
nos vamos a fijar cuando decreció por
cada año el número de casas vendidas es
decir lo que me voy a fijar es cuánto
cambio de aquí a 1988 cuánto decayó el
número de casas vendidas y me voy a
fijar también en cuánto decayó el número
de casas vendidas de 1988 al 89 y del 89
al 90 y vamos a ver si se parece
bastante que por ciento creo que sí a
ver veamos
me voy a tomar este color
aquí en 1987 estábamos parados justo por
aquí y bueno me voy a fijar aquí en el
libro creo que es un poquito más exacto
y entiendo un poco más lo que está
pasando estamos cerca de 156 mil estamos
como por aquí
qué es
156.000 y entonces empezamos en 156.000
y vamos a bajar hasta acá que es el
valor que tiene en 1988 que es este
valor de aquí y nos movemos para acá
para llegar a 1988 cuánto de crecimos en
la cantidad de casas vendidas bueno pues
vamos a ver en 1988 estamos como por
aquí que es cercano a 142 mil más o
menos 140 142 mil y si nosotros nos
fijamos en la diferencia que hay de aquí
acá pues son a 14 14.000 casas entonces
14 mil casas menos se vendieron de 1988
comparado con 1987 ok ahora vamos a
fijarnos que pasa de 1988 a 1989 pues
empezamos aquí como en 142.000 y vamos a
bajar otra vez de caímos hasta acá que
es el valor de casas que se vendieron en
1989 caminamos para acá y más o menos en
estamos abajito de este valor como en
128.000 más o menos por aquí estamos y
bueno cuánto hay de 128 mil a 142 mil y
te vas a dar cuenta que hay otra vez 14
14.000 casas menos se vendieron en 1989
que en 1988 ok creo que esto parece
tener sentido ahora vamos a ver en 1990
otra vez de creció a la cantidad de
casas que vendimos nos movemos en 1990 y
ahora estamos posicionados aquí más o
menos en este valor que es como 114 mil
114 mil y bueno cuánto hay de 114 mil a
128 mil siguiendo esta misma lógica son
como 14 mil casas menos que se vendieron
de 1989 a 1990 por lo tanto por año por
año se vendieron 14 mil casas menos en
cada uno de los años desde 1987 hasta
1990 y el inciso que tiene esto
respuesta es el inciso 0
ok recuerda que de hecho este tipo de
problemas lo más difícil es hacer la
gráfica y encontrar la representación
visual que resuelve el problema ya está
el inciso c y vamos a movernos al
siguiente problema el problema número 7
que por cierto el problema número 7
tiene una gráfica que si tú has visto
los vídeos les ya te seguramente vas a
reconocer nuevo nuevo tenemos algo así
tenemos una recta como por aquí
ok después tendremos algo por acá algo
más o menos así después tenemos algo
como por acá
ok tenemos algo parecido a esto y
después tenemos de aquí para acá tenemos
una figura parecida a ésta y qué datos
me dan bueno primero me dan algunos
puntos me dicen que este es el punto
este de aquí es el punto b esté aquí es
el punto este es el punto d este es el
punto
ok esto para empezar después me dicen
que este es un ángulo de 90 grados y que
este es un ángulo de 90 grados ok y me
dicen que este ángulo es x y este ángulo
es 10 y el problema dice lo siguiente sí
está de aquí y cede son ambas
perpendiculares hace ok son
perpendiculares pues tenemos tengo de 90
grados y por cierto si son
perpendiculares a esta recta se m ambas
son rectas paralelas eso tal vez nos
sirva bastante y sigue es igual a x2 es
muy importante
es igual a x x es igual a y ok y si la
longitud de ave es 8 la longitud que hay
de aquí acá es 8 y la longitud que hay
desde a de la longitud que hay de beade
es
434 kg cuánto vale c en cuánto vale la
longitud de s
desee
perfecto ok y este problema se me hace
bastante bastante interesante vamos a
ver aquí en conclusiones podemos llegar
lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que x es igual a 10 y eso lo vamos a
ocupar bastante para resolver este
problema si x es igual a james eso
quiere decir que a que x vale 45 grados
y que quien vale 45 grados fíjate bien
aquí tenemos un triángulo rectángulo y
por lo tanto la suma de estos dos los
que no son el ángulo de 90 grados debe
de ser 90 grados pero como x es igual a
james entonces me quedaría que x mayer
es igual a 90 grados ok y aquí pues x es
igual allí entonces x + x es igual a 90
grados
y entonces 2x es igual a 90 grados y de
aquí voy a obtener que x es igual a 45
grados eso me sirve bastante como x es
igual a 45 grados ya que también vale 45
grados entonces este ángulo
45 grados ok este ángulo también es de
45 grados pero no sólo eso
este de aquí el que es opuesto a este
ángulo de james también es de 45 grados
recuerda que tenemos dos rectas que se
interceptan estos dos ángulos son
iguales y si este ángulo de 45 grados y
dientes de 90 grados este también es de
45 grados esto también debe de ser 45
grados por lo tanto todos son de 45
grados y eso nos va a servir muchísimo
para entender bien este problema ahora
segunda parte si tú te acuerdas del
problema que resolvimos esa vez que era
muy parecido a éste lo que hice fue
tomarme un triángulo rectángulo pero que
traigo un rectángulo me tomé esto de
aquí fíjate bien es de este triángulo
imagínate tomarme esta parte de aquí a
algo más o menos así ok esto es justo lo
que quiero que es sé que esto es lo
mismo que se lo voy a tomar ahora este
triángulo
me voy a tomar este triángulo y fíjate
que está formando un triángulo
rectángulo fíjate en este triángulo que
voy a poner ahorita con este color tengo
este de aquí hasta acá tengo uno de los
lados que por cierto es la hipotenusa
tengo de aquí acá otro de los lados que
por cierto es uno de los catetos y de
aquí acá tengo otro de los lados que por
cierto es otro de los catetos aquí tengo
un triángulo y este triángulo es
rectángulo porque el rectángulo porque
yo estoy tomando esta línea esta línea
de color verde de tal manera que sea
paralela hace va a ser paralelas e iba a
tener la misma distancia que se por lo
tanto se encuentra este cateto ya
encuentra el problema
este cateto tiene como longitud c ok
pues vamos a llegar a la solución de
este problema y ya no está tan difícil
porque qué creés fíjate bien en este
triángulo de aquí es más lo voy a poner
a con color a con sus respectivos
colores aquí al lado para que lo veas y
lo visualices bien tengo no me pueden
usar el color rojo algo así después
tengo aquí a este lado a este lado que
me representa hacer tengo un lado muy
parecido a este ok y después tengo este
lado que lo voy a poner de color
amarillo que también nos va a servir ok
y además nosotros sabemos algunas cosas
de este triángulo lo primero que quiero
que te des cuenta es que este tramo no
tiene un ángulo de 90 grados es un
triángulo rectángulo y por eso cumple el
teorema de pitágoras eso en primer lugar
pero también sabemos que está al lado la
hipotenusa tiene un valor de
84 es 12 tiene 12 unidades
esta hipoteca ok ahora también por otra
parte sabemos que este ángulo mide 45
grados este ángulo de 45 grados y este
de aquí este de aquí también mide 45
grados date cuenta que mide lo mismo
porque la suma de estos dos me tienen
que dar un ángulo recto es decir 90
grados 45 grados más 45 grados 90 grados
o no podemos pensar adentro este
triángulo 90 más 45 más 45 grados me dan
180 grados pero este triángulo está
padrísimo porque además de tener un
triángulo rectángulo tengo un triángulo
que tiene dos ángulos de 45 grados y por
lo tanto podemos decir que es un
triángulo isósceles y los triángulos
isósceles cumplen una propiedad muy
importante cumplen que este lado tiene
que tener la misma longitud que este
lado y eso lo hemos visto muchas veces
por lo tanto la longitud de ccm que es
la que quiero que era esta de verde es
exactamente la misma que la longitud que
tengo aquí de hasta este punto hasta
este punto que le voy a llamar o de
hasta hoy es la misma longitud de agua
que de de ao que por cierto era la misma
que desea así que está perfecto tengo un
triángulo isósceles así que si este
cateto se llama x este cateto también le
podemos poner el nombre de x porque
tiene la misma longitud yo sí que te
parece si pensamos en el teorema de
pitágoras el teorema de pitágoras me
dice que uno de los catetos elevado al
cuadrado
este elevado al cuadrado más el otro
cateto elevado al cuadrado más x elevado
al cuadrado esto es exactamente lo mismo
que la hipotenusa que la hipotenusa
elevada al cuadrado que 12 elevado al
cuadrado y cuántos esto de aquí podemos
ya despejar el valor de x que es justo
atrás lo que vamos 2x cuadrada es lo
mismo que 144 ok ahora voy a dividir
esto entre 2 y me va a quedar que x
cuadrada es lo mismo que 144 entre 2 lo
cual es 72 72 perfecto y entonces puedo
decir que x es exactamente lo mismo que
la raíz de 72 la raíz positiva de 72
porque estamos hablando de una longitud
no podemos tomarnos longitudes negativas
ahora si x es igual a la raíz de 72 los
fijamos en nuestros incisos y no está y
no está porque esta raíz está
simplificada así que vamos a simplificar
la también nosotros a 72 voy a tomarme
el árbol de 32 72 tiene mitad la mitad
de 72 es 36 36 tiene sexta la sexta de
36 es 6 porque lo pongo así porque
entonces esto es exactamente lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de 2 por 6 por 6 o
dicho otra manera esto es exactamente lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de 2 por 6
elevado al cuadrado ha dicho otra manera
esto es lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada de
2 por la raíz cuadrada de 6 elevado al
cuadrado
y este cuadrado y esta raíz cuadrada se
pueden ir o sea que la raíz de 72 es
exactamente lo mismo que seis veces la
raíz de 2 seis veces la raíz de dos es
lo mismo que la raíz de 72 si nosotros
simplificamos la respuesta y seis veces
la raíz de dos si están nuestros éxitos
seis veces la raíz de dos es el inciso b
así que de lujo ya encontré la solución
de este problema lo único que hice fue
tomarme un triángulo rectángulo un
teorema de pitágoras y al final
simplificar una raíz cuadrada llegar a
que la raíz de 72 es exactamente lo
mismo que seis veces la raíz de 2 se me
ha acabado el tiempo hasta la próxima